Okay, so back to this picture real quick. You know,
I drew these little caches you know, these were the little
caches you've already seen before. Remember our program ask each
end presently right now is using a dictionary cache to store
stuff. And when we have multiple app servers, this can
create a problem. Because we have multiple caches. Which brings me
to my next quiz. Why is our dictionary cache problematic with
multiple app servers? It's not this is actually a trick question.
Multiple app servers means multiple caches. How do we
keep those caches in sync? Each app server may
have to hit the database to update its cache.
Or we'll caching data redundantly. Check all that apply.